joining us is former cdc director dr tom
frieden he is president
and ceo of the initiative resolved to
save lives which works to prevent
epidemics
dr frieden good morning thanks for
joining us i want to get straight to an
article you recently
wrote where you talk about how to reopen
safely and you reference immunity
passports explain what that is and how
it would work
well we don't know if this is going to
happen eureka but fundamentally what
we're seeing
is companies countries other places
giving people some certificate of
vaccination
with a certificate people might be able
to travel or enter certain places more
freely
the risk of this is that it will make
inequality even worse
if people have both more susceptibility
to the virus
and less access to the vaccine they'll
have even more problems but
done right immunity passports could be
one of a series of things
that could help us get to a new normal
as soon as possible but fundamentally
we're facing a very difficult few weeks
and few months there's not enough
vaccine yet
and we're seeing the highest levels of
cases hospitalizations
and deaths the u.s has since the start
of this pandemic
and recognizing how it could be
controversial these immunity passports
you say that there should be certain
standards what do you see those
standards as being for this to be
effective
first off absolute privacy no ability of
people to use that data for anything
else
second absolutely opt in you don't want
one you don't have to get one
and third complete transparency about
how they're being used
so that there are no surprises anywhere
but what
worries me most right now is that
congress get money out to states
and cities and counties to get the
vaccine into people's arms it's a great
accomplishment
that we have two highly effective
vaccines but money to deliver that
vaccine
money to engage communities money to
provide
pharmacists and nurses and doctors and
health departments with the wherewithal
to actually reach out to people and make
sure they get vaccinated
that's stuck in congress unless that
money gets out
we're going to have an even more deadly
winter as you're watching these
developments and with all of your
experience
are you satisfied with the vaccine
rollout thus far
i'm really impressed that we've seen the
kind of
effectiveness no one would have expected
90 plus percent effectiveness in less
than a year
from multiple vaccines that's partly
because our bodies do a good job
fighting
the virus as well but we're not there
yet the vaccines aren't here
it's going to be months before most of
us get vaccinated
and in that time we have to double down
on protection protocols
wear a mask avoid indoor space with
other people
increase ventilation and as soon as it's
your turn get vaccinated
you have 18 million americans that have
recovered that are documented as
recovering from covet 19 infections
but yet we still hear time and time
again we're learning a lot about coven
19 and even this new variant
do you have any sense of when scientists
will know how long
that immunity that natural immunity will
last
this is one of the things that we need
to learn as quickly as possible i wish
we knew more today
there is preliminary evidence that
suggests that there may be protection
for as long as six months or more
but it's really only as time passes they
will know how long the protection lasts
because there's no
perfect blood test to figure out if
you're immune to this virus yet
we hope that kind of a blood test could
be developed all right dr
tom frieden we really appreciate your
time thank you